results overnight show students at
Georgetown University support paying
reparations to help atone for the
school's past undergraduates voted
overwhelmingly yesterday in favor of a
$27 per semester fee to benefit
descendants of two hundred and seventy
two slaves who were sold by the school
in the 1800s the measure which still
needs the school's approval could sit
could set an important precedent for
other schools chip Reed spoke to
students on both sides of the debate and
he's at Georgetown's campus in
Washington chip both sides it sounds
like a lot of him a lot of the students
are standing on one side in particular
good morning absolutely they are people
here at Georgetown are waking up to the
fact that a solid majority of students
are willing to pay for the school's past
sins I talked to some students here
early this morning and they say they
believe it's a moral obligation we
needed to effect change in the
university we've all benefited from the
sales of these slaves previously and I
think that we have a duty now to show
our responsibility in the fact that we
did benefit from them Georgetown's
endowment is over 1.5 billion dollars
but in 1838 the school deep in debt sold
272 slaves to stay open in 2016 the
university's president apologized we
will seek forgiveness for our
participation in the institution of
slavery an institution that left this
institution divided now students here
have voted to pay an additional 27
dollars and 20 cents each semester that
would benefit the descendants of those
272 slaves
Georgetown students just need to
recognize how much other people have
sacrificed in order for them to be where
they are but opponents like freshman
Henry dye argued the effort to unchain
Georgetown's past takes Liberty from
today's students you say it's a slap in
the face at Liberty yes what do you mean
by this I don't believe we should moral
impose our values and other students and
the conversation isn't only taking place
at Georgetown I believe it's time to
start the National
conversation about reparations some 20
20 Democratic presidential candidates
have come out in support of reparations
a recent survey found a majority of
Democrats support studying ways to
compensate black Americans for the
impact of slavery Georgetown offered
preferential admission to their
descendants like this
New Orleans chef who came here as a
freshman at age 63 Georgetown students
are setting a precedent here by doing
something that's never been done before
in a statement the University says it
appreciates that students have made
their voices heard but the university
has not said that they will implement
the fee it's not clear when or if that
will happen major chip thank you very
much